Welcome back.
In lesson one,
we made single screen apps, but
most apps have more than
one screen of information.
In this lesson, we're going to focus
on view presentation and segways.
What are our options in iOS for
presenting a UI with
multiple pages of content?
How do new pages of content
make their way onto the screen?
We're going to talk about two
stock ways that Apple provides.
The first is through implementing
a navigation structure
as exemplified here in the messages app.
Notice that when I click on
a specific message stream,
the message details slides
in from right to left.
If I want to return to the previous
view, the main messages table in this
case, I can use the Back
button in the top left corner.
That Back button is always
there in iOS navigation.
A second way to bring a view onto
the screen is modal presentation,
like you see here when I press
the Compose button in Messages.
Modally presented views slide up
from the bottom of the screen.
Modal presentation is often used for
Alert views.
If I click on the camera for
a photo attachment,
an alert modal slides onto the screen,
giving me photo attachment options.
You can see that this alert view
also slides up from the bottom.
You'll be using a modally presented
image picker like this one
when you build MiMi